[Music]  Brad Pitt did have a family Christmas  after all a source telling et he saw his  kids over the holiday weekend our source  says the meeting was not arranged by  Angelina Jolie though and was quote  agreed to overall we want to make it a  family affair this comes after a source  told ET Brad was hopeful he'd see the  children for Christmas he spent  Thanksgiving without them the holiday  get-together comes after Pitt accused  Jolie of exposing their children and  disregarding their privacy rights in new  court documents docs filed earlier this  month revealed that the two stars have  been unable to agree on a custody  schedule for their six kids